if someone has already decided that they
are going to churn
it's too late to do anything but if the
marketing force
knows that uh chen is going to happen
then they have a window and a time a
time window where they can still act so
you can act on it
but you also get the insights welcome to
20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with loamy tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford data is eating the world by
storm
meet zohar bronfman ceo and co-founder
at pecan
tsar is an entrepreneur and ceo with a
phd in computational cognitive
neuroscience and a phd in history and
philosophy of science
his passion is enabling businesses to
drive tangible value with ai
his expertise include analytics ai deep
learning and computational psychology
as well as a strong background in data
science statistical data analysis
and business analytics zarb bronfman
thank you so much for joining me today
how are you
it's my pleasure michael i'm good thanks
i i'm doing i'm doing fine thank you i'm
very excited to have you here
and we have to start off with you know
your two different
phds how does it happen that you have
both a phd in computational cognitive
neuroscience
and a phd in the history and philosophy
of science
how does that even how does it even work
and what is history and philosophy of
science
yeah so actually the two questions are
related because uh
um at least from my perspective i think
the two phds are
quite complimentary so i started
learning
in parallel both philosophy and
cognitive
neuroscience and i felt that both fields
are very interesting
and had a lot to kind of
say also about the other field
and then i felt i want to understand
better this
aspect and i want to understand better
this aspect i didn't want to let go any
of those
so i did those two phds in parallel
uh history philosophy of sciences and
ideas
basically means that we ask ourselves
what are the main
uh constructs of thinking
that are um applied
again and again what changes not in the
not necessarily in the content of what
people
think at a certain point in time but
also in
how they think what are the methods they
are doing the structure the form
it really helps to put things in
perspective
people always think that now they have
uh like the one version of the truth
and that they know uh specifically what
is the
uh kind of uh case and if you
if you look at it in a more uh
historical perspective and a more
skeptical perspective
many times you uh realize that uh we
know
far later than what we think we know
right
and so how did you actually go about
doing these at the same time
these two these two phds
yep at the same time i split the week
into half
half of the week i was working on that
on the other
uh you know it's it sounds maybe crazy
but it's actually not
i think uh i think that uh when you are
within the kind of
zone of researching and uh and
and and experimenting and testing and
writing and so on
then adding additional layer is
far easier than um doing it separately
so it was actually quite an
amazing kind of experience that's
amazing and i know i'm really excited to
understand
how this all plays into what you're
doing today a year ago you came out of
stealth
with it with your series a right from
from dell and from s capital
talking about you know how do we provide
businesses with with a
pretty much drag and drop solution to
gain predictive insights
into things that they might not have the
capacity to do it themselves right
so a lot of a lot of places now that
have you know
specified a you know data science units
to answer specific questions like why do
our customers churn
or something like that well not
everybody can afford it or not everybody
has the expertise for that and we know
that we're
you know mckinsey i believe said that
we're gonna have a shortage of something
about half a million data scientists in
2025 or something crazy like that
and so obviously there's a huge market
here but zara
bring me up you know a little bit you
know 30 000 feet in the air what is the
world of data-driven analysis look like
and why do we need a solution like pecan
for today's businesses
yes so i think i think we can start from
uh
from the top here um we had revolutions
with regards to data uh during the
several last decades so first companies
started
gathering data then they started their
kind of uh
putting in place looking at it in a very
simplistic way then we had the bi
revolution
where companies started like to dice the
data slice and dice the data and kind of
get a better understanding of the
business uh dynamics that they have bi
became
uh both a necessity and a commodity so
today
it's very hard right to find an
organization
that's not running uh bi and
um we believe but we are obviously not
the only ones
that uh the next evolution the next
step is going to be uh
becoming ai driven it's not enough just
to understand
what happened you have to run more
advanced
forms of analysis of analytics that
gives you
kind of a direction or a hint
towards what is going to happen and
um like you said doing this crossing
this
chasm like moving from retrospective
point of view
to kind of a proactive or future looking
is something that requires a lot of
know-how
both know how in terms of dealing with
the data
and know how with uh understanding how
to relate those statistical methods
into the business uh necessities uh
what we found at pekin and how the story
uh here uh kind of unfolded
is that like you said there are many
data scientists out there
but the the the demand for data science
the demand for ai capabilities
is 10 times lower right and that's our
point of departure we understood that
this gap will never close
through additional data scientists and
what we decided
to do and i'll explain why in a minute
is to basically help the so-called
data analysts business analysts
wanted to help them cause this chasm
they wanted to help them
moving from just doing bi into also
doing ai
how did it happen it's a very so just to
clear the field yeah
just right right before that story so
give me that give me the you know the
analysis
what is the difference between today you
know you have people working in
companies doing you know
analysts doing bi and then you have data
scientists what is really you know
the core differences you see what is the
leap that that
you're talking about from simply you
know observing
bi versus you know creating doing
predictive analysis using data science
yeah so there are two probably um
two different kind of aspects into
moving from doing bi into ai
uh that traditionally you will have to
go through a lot of training
and a lot of kind of uh learning curve
moving from data analytics to machine
learning into data science
it will involve first and foremost
transitioning from sql
which is the basic tool of data
analytics
from sql to python or al or other
data science oriented languages and the
second
thing which is a maybe even more
important
but for sure under discussed
moving from a bi to an ai mindset
in terms of how you look at the data so
when you
bring forward data to a state where it's
ai ready
it has to include many components
that you don't necessarily do when you
run
bi there are many terms for that
some call it feature engineering some
call it ai structuring right
but it's obviously very challenging
difficult and has to you have to have a
deep understanding of the know-how
in predictive analytics so that you can
do this
data work that is ai looking
right and so what what is the actual
challenge with this is this
really just you know the is it the
manpower is it that
you know companies have generally the
same questions that they're asking and
and
so there's an opportunity here to to
actually go and consolidate this you
know this pattern behavior that a lot of
companies are doing
what what is really how because because
we're seeing a
crazy shift right now with businesses
that are making these leaps
are they asking the same questions are
they employing the same technologies
yeah it's a good question because um
the the answer at least from our
perspective is that
it's neither white nor black it's um not
exactly the same every company has its
own
specific business dynamics
data dynamics exact needs so there is
always a customized level
of how you fit the ai
algorithms to the problem on the other
hand there are many commonalities
so it's not like starting from scratch
this was actually one of our
realizations that you can take
one or two or several use cases
that are very important that are very
close to the right business value
and you can template them you can help
the users
walk through these use cases uh and then
have enjoyed the commonalities but still
have enough flexibility
so that they can tailor it to their
specific company's needs
right so you're talking about you know
common things like churn
or how do we get people in e-commerce to
spend more time or or to add more items
to the cart
and a lot of these things that you know
are on one hand
you know we can generalize them in a
sentence to pretty much every e-commerce
you know website or company at the same
time every e-commerce company will have
their own specific use case of how they
want it done
and how does their data work and what is
the pipeline that they're using right
so so that that is so the black and
white are sort of like the questions
but then how do you you actually want to
go and employ those questions with
solutions that's
that's where you need the customization
right
exactly so what's actually happening
today with pecan
and how do you actually go about you
know introducing this to the market is
it is it easy to explain to companies
like hey listen we have these tools to
give you better predictive analysis we
can transition you from bi to ai
or are you getting some resistance for
that
so i i have to say uh um
quite surprisingly obviously there's
always
uh you know healthy skepticism
and uh when you bring forward something
new people always look at it and try to
understand
whether it's real um how good it is and
so on and so forth
but i have to say touchwood
we are quite fortunate to be able to
resonate
with the uh with our uh partners
prospects and so on and so forth
i think there's a very healthy
combination
between use cases that people already
understand they need
that people understand they want and
also the pain
of not having enough data science
resources which is very evident this is
these are like things that we don't need
to
educate the market and then we let the
product talk for itself
i think the the um the greatest
um kind of thing that we bring to the
world
is that data analysts
have a sincere desire in moving into the
next step
they are actively trying today through
uh courses through academic degrees
through um experience in the companies
working with friends
they are trying to find ways and how can
i
drive a more advanced analytics how can
i move from bi to ai
and in that regard we have a very strong
pull
from the market because the market is
there
it's now a question of the technologies
that will enable it and this is what
we are racing against obviously
so do you see a future where you have
where you have
companies more employing these
technologies that are enabling
current workforce to to conduct more
thorough you know analysis or do you see
really
investing more in data scientists or is
it some sort of combination of both
where
on one hand you do need your internal
data scientist to solve the meaningful
questions but you can also use
solutions like pecan ai to solve for the
more for the more common questions that
others might also have that same use
case
so i i think absolutely option to a data
scientist
will always be i think extremely
important
for organizations and when you can
hire enough data scientists and when you
can
employ enough proficient data science
expertise on
core use cases that are very important
for your business
it is probably the right thing to do
the thing is that it will ever just
increase the fact that organizations
have hundreds of questions hundreds of
avenues of advanced analytics that they
need to explore a need to kind of
solve they will never have enough
data science capabilities and then it
will be a question of resource
allocation here i'm taking
uh this group of data scientists here
i'm taking this group of data analysts
sometimes i can cross uh talk between
them that will become
the natural um evolution of how data
science is being uh done in
organizations so sure right
so one of the things that i enjoyed most
was was studying the
case studies that he showed on the
website of how you're actually going
about him with you know sometimes only a
few hours of dedicated time you're able
to create some pretty impressive changes
in the way that an organization
communicates with its users or makes
decision decisions on
how to upsell or how to show different
different things to the users can you
share with me a few of those case
studies just to get a perspective of
of what is possible when you when you do
make that leap from
you know bi to ai even with a software
like p can ai
sure so i think you you gave uh you gave
kind of uh
a quick example earlier chern is an
example that is very easy to follow
and like you said in direct to consume
or in a
digital commerce or environments like
that
we have a lot of customers a lot of
users that have a journey
this journey has all of the data
footprints
stored you have the data in your
warehouse you analyze it as an bi
specialist
you provide insights look after 11
sessions the user decides that
he or she are not going to buy and they
churn
but if you start digesting the data
through a data science oriented platform
what you will be able to achieve is that
even
before things happen you can actually
see that for example this user is very
likely to churn
uh uh um for example because of price so
you also get the kind of
underlying reason or factor that
contributed to the prediction
and the other user even if they have the
same likelihood to churn
are going to churn because of um
customer service just as as an example
so what you can get out of that are
several layers of treatment
first of all you can devise a very
tailored
very personalized action right to kind
of
preempt turn before it happens because
if someone has already decided
that they are going to churn it's too
late to do anything
but if the marketing force knows that
uh chen is going to happen then they
have a window and a time a time window
where they can still act so you can act
on it but you also get the insights
that are different from the bi insights
because they are
forward-looking so the insights can
guide you into
what are the issues with the product
what is the issue with the user journey
what are the segments or the micro
segments
that quit for different reasons and uh
eventually what we
see in our uh cases in our real cases
are sometimes reduction of
more than 20 percent in generates which
is
you know it's strategic this is like ceo
stuff that i like seeing the slides and
i'm saying i don't believe it
we are so happy to have these cases and
obviously
uh we are continuing to build those uh
uh day after day i think one of the most
impressive things that i'm gathering
from this and
and i've seen it firsthand you know in
the you know in the industry
is that at the end we're talking about a
lot of low-hanging fruits right you have
a lot of these
you know you we're at the point where
companies are now beginning to
understand that you know data collection
is the beginning
so you you can you and you know pretty
much every company is using enough
of these ready-made tools the analytics
tools to be collecting the right data
and now they're really like you're
saying the evolution is to take that and
go from bi to ai
and it's pretty fascinating how you know
you have some things that are just
low-hanging fruits that
you know by employing you know
relatively you know linear simple models
you can actually
do some some really great predictive
analysis and and
like you mentioned at the end it's all
about again the personalization
it's not about you know one size fits
all but it's about you know how do you
make personalized
personalized flow and and space for
every customer so that you know as a
company how to allocate your resources
if you have a thousand leads from today
how do you know which ones to call back
how do you know which ones to prioritize
how do you know which ones
you know you're probably not going to
get in the first place so you should
maybe not even
not even worry or maybe even advise them
for trust not
to move on with the purchase so i think
it's just it's just fascinating what you
guys are doing i love
data driven problems and i think that
you know companies that solve this
for on an industry-wide level uh are are
just fascinating and so thank you so
much for joining me today it was really
really great
uh thank you finally the most important
question
uh but actually i've i have two
important questions first of all
how how does one walk for so many
kilometers in the day
how how's that possible so yeah i'll
i'll i'll say a word about that because
uh maybe it will help others try and do
that as well
during the covered area because you know
we had so much
time spent sitting in front of the
computer i decided that every
call every session every meeting that i
can take walking
i'll do it working and uh
first of all it's been an amazing
decision one of the best decisions i've
ever i
ever made i've been um taking so many
calls working
it's a tremendous um
help to me to be concentrated and kind
of uh
motivated invigorated so that's amazing
and i've been
uh averaging quite a lot of miles at 25
miles a day roughly
so um it's very much
unbelievable very much recommended
unbelievable it kind of reminds me of
the imitation game i have to say
just a little bit a lot of the scenes of
touring uh turned running but
you know we'll leave that comparison for
another time it's all the most important
question
three words that you would use to
describe yourself oh
three words to describe myself um
i think the it's it's it's a hard
question to reduce one's uh
uh entire being into three words
i would say um determined
creative builder love it
thank you very very much thank you so
much just the start of a long journey
but
already making a huge impact and thank
you very much one step and then stay
safe
all the best
[Music]
you